I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense what did you find inspired you
then my potential like truly the truth
and I went on an airplane and this woman
next to me looked at me and she said
you're so full of light and I at that
time literally just started this quantum
shift I still had a lot of ego and a lot
of arrogance I was working for Leigh
Steinberg I was running the most notable
sports agency in the world my friends
were the most famous people I still was
rich and I looked at her and I said
thank you and she said do you meditate
and I literally went into a diatribe so
how long ago this is like the two years
before I went bankrupt so I was 39 yeah
that's excited somebody's talking about
meditating back then yeah and her name
was dr. Sangeeta sahi a medical doctor
who's later I found out a healer Wow and
but anyway she looked at me and said you
meditate I wanted to do this diatribe I
try to say it exactly but I looked here
and said meditation meditation I don't
have time to meditate people are high
sick and broke on their mom's couch
meditate those are your words not
someone else's you were describing them
earlier you're like they're people that
are high stick and broke know those are
your words exactly I'm telling her
straight out literally how could I
manage I made everything myself
I literally listed out what I had I said
Ferrari of pours like she's like he
needs to work on his narcissus oh yeah
yeah I listed out like the Ferrari the
porch the house is a ski mountain golf
course I run Leigh Steinberg have you
heard at least I'm work ever see the
movie Jerry Maguire like this is where
my ego was still and she looked at me
and she said oh that's too bad
she goes because I could teach you to
vibrate faster and I'm looking at her
like what what she's like yes she goes
like I'm married that's not appropriate
right I'm thinking close to that I'm
literally like this me alone quite the
India she goes the earth vibrates the
slowest then plants animals humans then
sound then light then thought she was do
you know what vibrates the fastest and I
was literally still arrogant like no she
was the truth and literally the hairs on
my arms stood up she was the truth
vibrates the fastest you cannot be aware
of anything that vibrates right just
lower than you I can elevate your
vibration so you can be aware of the
truth don't you want to know the truth I
could teach you whether to buy or sell
that's a no where
yeah and she invited me to workshop yeah
oh wow and I don't know why all I mean
like did you go I did and my wife had
such skepticism because I was so lost I
told her I'm staying in India an extra
few days to go to this workshop I met
this doctor saying Geeta cyi
she thought I was going to a Little John
concert right like literally I was lying
again and this was gonna be the end of
my relationship she had to Google the
woman to figure out she was truly a
saint of meditation expert on healer a
medical doctor Wow and I went through
all these things like including bodies
gasps rather attracted her i next thing
out a doubt in fact I still am a healer
myself I did my first body scan and I
remember it to a tee where you know
someone gives you your hands and you
stay in their body for energy and I'm
not a believer at this time but I'm
already getting feel like wow I'm pretty
connected like this is really true and
the woman that I was doing with I
literally see all this red in her
stomach and then on a right big toe it's
like a huge energy burst and so you know
doctor saw he's like what do you see
there and I'm like oh I see
you know red in your stomach and I see
on her big right toe like this energy
just swirling and I open my eyes because
I can feel the lady like this yeah she
goes oh yeah I'm having really bad
stomach issue I've been the doctor on my
medication and I stub my toe this
morning and lost my nail on that big toe
Wow I'm literally like did I just do
this like weird skin but this is also a
way that you know I've found where it's
myself for the people around me that are
maybe mediums or something like that
like you do little tests on people
around you and then it develops the
talent and you know further to trust it
more so that you can really start to use
it
[Music]